it makes a big difference we estimate it
of around 200 million pounds a year
that's roughly equivalent to what the
British music industry invests every
year into new artists so it's a huge
amount of money being lost to the music
industry the music industry is
tremendously successful for the UK and
we could be even more successful if we
can crack down on people accessing
content illegally was there a suspicion
in your mind that the likes of Google
and Bing we're turning a blind eye to
piracy and to file-sharing well I think
clearly they're the gatekeepers to the
internet and search is an incredibly
important means through which fans
discover music so for us yes they need
to do more
obviously they reap enormous benefits
from their businesses from search and
they've given consumers a tremendous
facility now which we all use every day
but at the same time they have a
responsibility to make sure that they're
not helping illegal businesses and we
found when you search for British music
all too often most of the links that you
find in search results even at the very
top are to illegal sites and we think
that's wrong so how effective do you
think this is going to be and by when
will you start to see meaningful results
from now for example I'm I look for some
of these sites this morning on Google I
still found them without too much
difficulty well that's why what we're
mainly concerned with our fans who
haven't decided they're gonna go out and
you know take the music illegally
they're just looking for the music to
access there we think it's really
important that they're given access to
the legal sites first so what this code
will do I mean we'll all work together
to try and make sure that illegal sites
are demoted out of search results much
more quickly so yes it should make a
difference but there's clearly a lot of
work still to do but it's your suspicion
though that they were genuinely turning
a blind eye to it before I mean what
sort of response did you get from the
likes of Google when you raised this
previously I think it's fair to say that
they acknowledge it's a problem they
acknowledge that they have to be part of
the solution but that we want them to go
further so I see this code as the first
step in that direction
to getting the search engines to be more
collaborative partners in solving the
problem I think everybody has an
interest in an Internet that rewards
creativity the creative industries of
the fastest growing sector of the
economy so many talented people here
want to work in creative jobs but
obviously that can only happen if we
deal with the illegal sites they don't
reward anyone but isn't the problem this
though Jeff that people who are
genuinely determined to find these kind
of sites and indulge in this sort of
behavior there's always going to be a
way for them
to do so they'll always find a way I
think we have to recognize there's a
hard core who perhaps will always be
determined to take something for nothing
and you know that's a shame I think
personally the artists deserve to be
rewarded for their work and that we're
only going to see innovation on the
Internet if people are rewarded for
their creativity how important is it
being for you to have the UK government
behind you
I think it's been pivotal we should say
thank you to Matt Hancock in particular
the mystery of culture and the IP
Minister Joe Johnson have both played an
absolutely pivotal role in bringing
everybody to the table
I guess banging some heads together and
trying to get agreement so the UK
government role has been very important
they're going to stay involved in this
process to make sure that you know this
isn't just a piece of paper but rather
it is kick-starts a really truly
effective collaboration between all the
parties and so you're saying it needed
someone with the muscle of the UK
government to get the likes of Google
around the table yes I think that the UK
government's really showing a leadership
role here the digital economy is
tremendously important for the UK I
think the UK recognized that we need to
take a lead here we need to create a
digital economy that works for business
and works for artists and I think this
is a great step in that direction